Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for April 2nd,
2018 what's going on?
How
welcome to April everybody.
Oh,
you didn't think you'd make it did Jeff?
Oh the God damn snow just kept falling out of the fucking sky and all these
fucking liberal concept talking about global warming.
Oh yeah.
Oh fucking cool.
You off of my fucking toes.
You cunt.
Um,
global warming.
I love on people who fucking,
when it snows in the winter,
people just go to global warming.
Um,
I don't know,
Bill.
Don't try to be a scientist.
Okay.
You've tried to be a lot of things on this podcast and failed miserably.
Why would you pick such as smart vocation to start off with?
Well,
you know,
cause I'm an arrogant ass.
Um,
oh.
Did I sleep well last night?
You know,
I,
uh,
okay.
Um,
I,
you know,
I got my big,
big birthday coming up my 50th birthday.
So my deal was there's a certain weight I wanted to get down to and a one of
those gene companies,
you know,
that advertise on my podcast.
I can't remember the fucking name of them.
It's one of those people,
you know,
we were two broke college kids,
so we started a fucking Jean factory kits.
Like,
well how the fuck did you do that?
Thought you were broke.
You know,
you're trying to be all down to earth.
And next thing you know,
you gotta you gotta fucking company.
What are you telling me?
You just sold them yourself.
Yeah,
we'll make you a pair of pants.
That'll be about a,
I don't know what we got to learn how to,
so first,
uh,
well cause we're Bronx sir.
We can't afford any sewing machines and people that know how to operate them.
Okay.
Apology accepted.
And I'm sorry too for yelling,
but you know,
if you want jeans from us,
it's just going to take a moment.
So stand up on this thing so I can measure your inseam.
So anyways,
they sent me a pair of jeans that were a 30 to 32 when I had,
you know,
I was 34,
32.
Uh,
and now I'm 33,
32.
So my,
my goal is to get back to that.
I think that's the size that I had in high school slash when I started,
um,
started doing comedy.
So I'll see if I can,
I don't know.
I don't know if I wanted to do that.
Cause you know,
this one of those things where like if you're,
uh,
if you're,
you're high school weight when you're my age but you never really went up,
I don't think you look that bad.
But like if you get down to a high school weight and you are actually like an
adult males weight,
uh,
you kind of look like you're dying.
Um,
but we'll see.
Uh,
I am back on little health kick here.
Um,
I told you last Monday,
you know,
I did the go Idm,
I'm EGM.
And um,
I had a shot of Jameson before the show,
you know,
sort of a tradition,
drink a little shot of fucking courage.
And then after the show I went out,
I was just going to have one beer and was going to go home,
but I showed up in,
somebody already bought me another Jameson.
So I had that.
Then I had a beer.
But you know,
the shot in the beer was stretched way out between the first year.
The whole show went by like three hours.
Um,
and I had a couple of waters after the first shot,
so it was really just a shot of Jameson in the beer.
And the next day I woke up.
And,
um,
aside from the fact that I stayed out till one in the morning,
my lovely daughter gets up at like,
oh,
six,
six 30,
I just woke up and I just,
I wasn't worth a shit until like fucking two in the afternoon.
And,
um,
I was just like,
I,
I can't,
I can't do this.
I just can't fucking do this.
So I didn't drink
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
and then Friday I performed at arguably my favorite theater in the country.
Um,
the Brady theater in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
And I cannot expect fucking place and the people that show up there and the way
the laugh sound in that room and the sound and the look of that fucking place,
it's,
it's unreal in the amount of people too,
who've never been there.
When I told him I was going to Tulsa,
Oklahoma,
they will like Tulsa,
Jesus,
you know,
thinking that it was going to be like tumbleweeds and stuff.
It's a really fucking hipster replace like the food scene alone
is crazy and you know when the food is really good then you're going to have the
record store,
which I like the record store.
I don't necessarily like,
you know,
the Douche is that go in there,
I,
you know,
I'm a Douche.
Stupid.
Like I was actually riffing about that on stage with people.
Like,
dude,
it's sad,
so much better.
It's like I can't hear the difference.
I can't hear that.
Didn't really know the CD was,
it was a lie man.
Everything got compressed into,
they just get into the whole fucking sound thing.
And I'm just,
I just like records because they reminded me when I was a kid,
you know,
and you feel like you kind of got more for your money.
Well,
you know,
you open it up and there was all these pictures on the inside sleeve and all
that shit.
Um,
I don't know.
As opposed to now you just downloaded off off like iTunes and it's just floating
in the air man.
Um,
so anyways,
I uh,
so gifts getting off stage that night and was like,
I'm not going to drink.
And I just felt like,
uh,
you know the habit of me doing that being like,
come on man,
just have fucking one.
Cause I was flying after the show.
It was like that show and Tulsa every fucking reason why I ever wanted to be a
comedian.
It was so much fucking fun.
I was barely doing my act.
I forget what I did.
Oh,
I know why I,
I connected,
I flew to Dallas,
connected there and then went up to Tulsa.
And um,
the second I got on the plane and you like,
they was just like three of four really big people,
you know,
not just fat but just big ass fucking people.
So I was just riffing on that.
One of them.
Two people was so big and fat,
they had to use wheelchairs.
So I was just referred on the fact,
you know,
are you really helping them out if you're wheeling them around like a fucking
toddler and you know it's like,
I'm not trying to like bring back segregation here,
but I really think wheelchairs to just be for people who can't fucking whose
legs don't work.
It's like your legs work,
you asshole lay off the cookies.
MMM.
I actually said because see it guys so fat that even if he has a full head of
hair you can still see most of his scalp.
You know,
cause even that it's just even as head is getting like fat,
it's like stretching out.
It was unbelievable.
This guy sat in the chair in front of me and the fucking chair,
it was like coming down and it was one of those things like an action movie.
Like it's just going to fucking stop or am I going to get crushed to death?
And it stopped about two inches from the bridge of my nose.
I think I audibly exhaled like you know,
cause it's like
Ah,
I mean you,
that guy tried to get up.
It'd be like my daughter,
she still can't do like a sit up,
you know what I mean?
She just doesn't have the strength.
That is hilarious.
She gets like three inches up and she's making this face and she stared at you
and then I just start laughing and then she laughs,
which you know,
makes her fall back down again.
MMM.
So anyways,
she said Dada now all the time and she was in the crib this morning and I'm
always the one that goes out and I get her and then,
uh,
you know,
pick her up and I've,
I've figured out,
because she gives the best hugs,
but she's also,
you know,
a toddler now,
so she just wants to look at everything.
So when she says she only does it for half a second,
so the way to tricker into giving you a nice minute long hug it,
you've got to sing to her and she loves sea itsy bitsy spider right now.
Like that,
that's her fucking jam.
Right.
So I just come out there and she's like,
hi,
hi.
Hi.
You know,
showing off the word that she knows how to say.
And then I just pick her up and she gives me the quick hug and then immediately
is pointing over to the changing table cause you know,
she wants to get that over with so she could then go in and watch a little
cartoons,
you know,
and drink a bottle of milk.
Right.
But I got it down now I just pick her up and I just go,
oh,
the itsy bitsy spider went up the water spout.
Dow came though raid and washed the spider out.
And by then she's already later head.
I sing,
it's sweeter than that.
I kind of pushed through with you guys,
didn't want to creep you out,
but she fucking uh,
puts her head down on my shoulder.
It just sits there and is content.
I could sing the song like six times in a row and she'll just lay there.
And then when I get sick of that song,
I just sing the abcs and uh,
and then she does this thing,
a few squeezer and you go give me a hug or too little fat hands.
She grabs two handfuls of your shirt.
That's fucking adorable.
Um,
I'm starting to realize why dad's cry at their daughter's wedding.
You know,
I used to think it was some weird shit though.
They would just like thinking like,
ah,
this guy is good.
Even if even if they haven't already bagged,
he's gonna Bang are now tonight.
You Know,
God,
you pluck an asshole.
And I got to pretend like I like,
um,
you know,
thinking like that shit.
It isn't the thinking about the Etsy.
Like I used to sing this kid,
the itsy bitsy spider,
you know,
where did the fucking decades go?
So anyways,
going back to my,
uh,
you know,
the booze and shit,
like,
um,
I dunno.
So then,
uh,
you know that man,
it's like,
that's already going to be the greatest moments in my life are going to be
those.
And I just don't want to be all banged up and extra tired and God forbid grumpy.
So,
um,
I dunno.
So then San Antonio,
I did two shows,
fucking amazing crowds down there.
Um,
and once again,
I just carried over whatever happened in Tulsa.
Uh,
I've learned how to do that though as far as like what happens as you know when
you go out and one night you just in the zone and you're not even doing your act
the next night you come on stage,
you're like hoping that you're going to be in the zone again the night before.
You weren't hoping that you are going to be in the zone.
It just happened.
So then you going out there and now you're hoping it's going to be like last
night.
So now you're walking out on stage and you're thinking about last night so
you're not,
you're not like mentally they're not to get all trippy.
So what I do is I try to let go of the last night but do the same fucking thing
that I did in that.
I'll just talk about something that I'd just fucking saw except this time it's
in San Antonio and I just came out and I was bitching about the fact that I
didn't realize that the final fucking fall Pfoa was in San Antonio.
I kind of figured it out when it was 500 bucks a night.
At a Goddamn red roof inn,
but by the fucking airport.
Um,
and then it was just like,
this is going to be a real problem with transportation.
I had to hire this company,
you know,
to make sure they could pick me up the airport.
Get Dean,
you,
it was out there with del Rio del rape.
Fucking murdered so hard in Tulsa.
He had a sustained round of applause.
Like he had to wait before he introduced me.
That's how fucking hard this guy's killing.
So you've got to go see dean when he's out in the road,
actually watched them do like a full set.
I know he has an album coming out to uh,
on vinyl I believe,
speaking of records.
So,
um,
anyways,
I went out and just did the same thing and on both shows I just,
you know,
fucked around and rift about some shit and it just got me into this place.
And then it was fun cause I was,
you know,
both nights I was teasing people about having ar fifteens and telling them how
they should go about talking to people on the left about why you have an ar 50.
And um,
it just,
it just was a fucking great night.
Um,
both nights.
So what is my point?
So my point is,
I just,
you know,
through,
I was watching the Zen diaries of Garry Shandling,
this fucking incredible documentary that Judd Apatow did.
Um,
and it is such the standup comedian experience.
I literally had to take breaks from it.
I had to shut it off or I hit pause,
I'll be watching the thing right.
And I would just,
something he would write down because Gary I guess kept all these diaries and
stuff and judges would just like film,
like just a line or two that he wrote.
And uh,
it would either be something that I thought or something that I never realized
and it's just like,
yeah,
that's it.
Or just an experience that I had and obviously all my experiences are in a way
less like whatever experience he had at the tonight show or hosting the Emmy's.
I had plane,
you know,
uncle fuckees in Swampscott,
Massachusetts.
Um,
but I just kept fighting.
I would be watching this show is hilarious.
It'd be watching this show and he would be like in the other room.
And then she just hit me in the other room just going like,
ah,
and
um,
just watching how the way this thing is put together,
I'm a,
I'm not going to ruin it for you,
but just seeing how like one like major event when you're a kid with your
developing mind,
be it positive or negative,
how it just shapes and informs the rest of your life and the way that it is done
is so fucking masterful in this documentary.
And um,
I don't know,
I just can't say enough things about it.
So I was sitting there after having watched it,
or actually I'd watched up to the,
like the first half hour of this,
of part two.
I mean,
it's like four and a half hours long.
It's,
and it's fucking amazing.
And I was actually out on the road going,
fuck,
I wish I could watch the rest of that right now.
You know,
it's just,
you know,
I,
it's hard to find four and a half hours when you get the,
you know,
you've got a 14 month old to just sit down in a row.
So I was out there and I was just thinking about,
you know,
I was mad at myself that I went out after Tulsa and I had a drink.
I had one drink and then somebody sent one over to me.
And of course I'm going to drink that cause I didn't want to be rude and you
know,
I'm a bit of a booze hound and,
um,
I kinda just was sticking to myself.
Like,
uh,
I told myself I wasn't going to drink until fucking June and I already fucked up
on the road.
Not even cause I wanted to just start it like,
you know,
I'm flying high and fucking wide awake.
I don't want the night to end,
you know,
um,
to awake to fucking go is still asleep.
I got an 8:00 AM flight,
let me just fucking have one.
And then next thing you know,
I'm fucking staying out till like one in the goddamn morning.
I've got to get up at six for the flights.
What am I doing?
I should be out here getting sleep for when I come back,
so I gotta be a better dad.
This is stupid.
So,
because I watched,
you know,
at that point,
the first half of the zen diary sing,
I actually had a notebook because I was writing out some of the drum parts for
these songs.
I got to sing with Dell Rake at the sinks,
sorry,
play on Tuesday night out here at the Avalon.
And uh,
I was just like,
why don't you just write down,
you know,
these goals?
Because somebody would feed sometimes if you just fucking think them,
they're not real.
And then if you say,
I'm a write 'em down anyways,
how my brain works,
it becomes real.
So I just kind of wrote it down.
The shit that I wanted to do,
you know,
the shape I wanted to be and,
and uh,
yeah,
I just wrote down then I was just for the month of April.
I'm just like,
I'm not smoking any fucking cigars.
I'm not drinking any booze.
Um,
you know,
not watching any fucking porn.
Do you know,
fucking stupid online porn,
lonely shit you do on the road and that porno,
I swear to God it's going to come out like how bad that is for you,
your brain,
you know what I mean?
Cause I find myself that when I watch porno laughing,
like I'm watching a sitcom,
there's always something that just strikes me as fucking funny.
Um,
yeah,
it's just like,
I shouldn't be laughing while was,
is this weird?
Right.
And then you also think like,
you know,
you go back,
I don't know how many fucking years,
like if you went back like a hundred years and you showed somebody like a
laptop,
it'd be like,
you know,
you realize you can watch this and you just put it on to,
I swear to God they would burn you at the stake.
Like you were a fucking,
which
like how fucked up it would be that a human being could sit down anytime they
wanted and just watch endless hours of that shit.
Um,
I bet I did some brain damage something.
It's like you fucking,
it's like you,
I've really feel like,
um,
destroying my soul by watching that shit,
on some level.
So I was like,
good to not do that.
I'm going to fucking continue to work out all of these,
just sort of these,
these,
I dunno,
health goals and then I got to work on my,
my,
uh,
my anger issues because my daughter doesn't realize I have them yet and it's
just inevitable she's going to,
I've been doing this joke on my act out likes a couple of times.
She's seen me start to like,
she,
if she honestly hasn't even met me yet as far as like who I really am,
she's met the side of me that I'm proud of,
but all this shit that I'm ashamed of,
she hasn't really met yet.
She's seen a couple of glimpses,
but I'm always able to joke my way out of it.
Like,
Oh,
Daddy,
oh,
you see the laptop through the weird show?
She's laughing because she doesn't know what those words mean or that,
that behavior is fucked up.
Right.
So I dunno,
that's just shit I have to work on.
So,
uh,
I don't know.
I don't think I would have written that down and it would have become real had I
not watched that.
Uh,
Zen diaries,
a Gary Shandling,
I'm telling man,
you gotta you gotta fucking see that thing and speaking with HBO is killing it
this month because they have like a,
they got one on a documentary on like Andre the giant,
Martin Luther King.
Um,
Elvis.
I mean,
they just,
and I think it comes out every Wednesday.
So if you're not watching the NHL rivalry fucking Wednesday,
uh,
or even if you are just taped some of these things,
because you know,
HBO,
they always do everything fucking top shelf.
It's going to be amazing.
So anyways,
I have some things to,
uh,
have I made you guys laugh once yet?
I've just been fucking being an idiot here talking about this shit.
But it's also,
I just feel like I'm doing is fair.
Um,
all right.
I've got a couple of announcements here.
One,
I'm transitioning.
Okay.
Uh,
October six,
2018 I'm going to be in Bridgeport,
Connecticut.
All right.
At Webster Bank arena.
Uh,
general public on sale will be Friday,
April 6th at noon.
April six,
one I'm gonna be in Pittsburgh,
but two shows.
Um,
what an idiot then people already know I'm going to be there.
I'm literally hyping other shows.
I'm trying to hype this new one.
October six,
2018.
Bridgeport,
Connecticut,
Webster Bank arena.
General public on sale will be Friday,
April 6th at noon.
The presale starts today.
Today.
All right.
The code is Billy Baldwin.
You get it.
Billy bald when all capital letters.
No spaces.
B,
I.
L L y.
B.
A L D for The win win.
Um,
anyways,
you know,
it's fucking hilarious.
I want won.
I did the Brady Theater in Tulsa.
I pull up and,
uh,
there's this one dude standing outside,
you know,
the fucking,
the stage door.
All right.
And,
uh,
I got to sing.
I hate meeting people before the show,
after the show,
I don't give a fuck,
but before the show I can't,
it's just,
it's weird to me.
It's like I haven't done my fucking thing that I do.
So,
um,
I'm thinking about doing that,
you know,
I don't know.
I,
I no problem after,
before it just weirds me out.
So I got it and this guy goes,
he's like,
hey bill,
a big fan of getting mega your gun.
I go to sign his fucking shit and all of a sudden I feel like this sticky thing,
like I had like syrup in my hand or something.
I handed back to Penn and I looked down at my fucking hand is just cool,
calm.
I get the ink,
the pen exploded.
Oh fuck.
I look like I don't know what I look like.
So I walk in and it's really like thick.
Okay.
Like black or blue ink.
I went on the bathroom and I'm like trying to scrub the skin off my fucking hand
and um,
you know,
del,
Ray's laughing at me and shit.
Look at Louis Shit,
you know my hands are so pasty,
so I got this.
It's like my hands are in black face,
right?
So I'm fucking scrubbing this shit off and I was able to get most of it off,
but there's still like,
you know,
you can see the state of it.
MMM.
I wish I talked about that when I went out on stage.
But I did.
So I went out and I did the show and as I go to walk off the stage,
who comes walking down to the front of the stage?
Jay Bill,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
I already met you.
I already signed you shit.
And I already got the ink all over my head.
But he's getting married.
So going over Shay,
man.
Thank you.
I go,
you know,
good luck with your marriage and everything.
Yeah.
So that I fucking walk out,
right?
Yeah.
Just talking to Dana.
I'm like,
Dude,
how fucking unbelievable is that theater?
He's like,
Oh,
you know,
the sound is unbelievable.
Crab a blah blah.
You know,
Dean,
that show was fire,
right?
So we go outside
and we go to lead the places like 10 or 15 people there,
right?
So I'm fucking day guys,
thanks for coming out and talk to people,
you know,
signing shit or whatever and this fucking guy comes up again and he wants me to
sign more shit.
I'm thinking in my head,
it's just like this look guy coming back from fucking seconds.
I mean,
why did he,
you know,
there's other people here.
We already did this and I shook your hand.
So I go to sign something fucking else study has and I feel this sticky thing.
He gave me this say fucking pen again and I was so stupid that I went and I
grabbed the thing and I just looked to you,
you fucking asshole.
I go,
you've got an exploded pen here.
And then he just starts laughing
and now I got to shit on my fucking hand,
my hands,
all the exact same,
almost the exact same fingers and all that.
Obviously I'm not ambidextrous switch and one hands.
I'm just like Indeed's fucking,
and then dean signs on that foam walked back into the fucking car.
We got ink all over our hands.
The drivers laughing his ass off at us because he saw me when I went in and go
their fucking ass.
All that exploded pen.
So as,
this is the thing,
as I go to get in the car,
the same dude who I already signed,
his shit,
got ink on my hand,
shook his head after the fucking show,
you know,
as I'm walking off stage,
shook his hand,
sign more shit,
got more fucking exploded,
Aecom my hand,
he then goes,
he goes,
hey pill,
you got a Po address that I can send these six to these pictures.
I took on his cell phone.
Just go,
no,
you fucking asshole.
I got a call over my head.
And again,
he just starts laughing.
Then I felt bad.
I go,
good luck with your marriage.
And we get in the cars would drive it away and I just was just riffed about the
poor woman that is going to marry that fucking guy,
you know?
Cause it was something about him.
You couldn't get mad at him.
But I really think that debt exploding pen was a fucking omen.
Yeah.
You know that he was just going to be like,
I don't know.
Jesus Christ.
So anyways,
I,
um,
let me read a little bit of advertising then I'll tell you about the San Antonio
going down there with the final four experience going on.
MMM.
Where the hell is it?
What do we got here?
What are we got this week?
Oh,
Indo Chino.
Talk about how a made to measure suit fits compared to a generic off the rack
suit.
Well,
unless you're like a generic off the rack size,
I imagine your ankles are going to be showing and your balls are going to be
snugged or uh,
you know,
you're going to be looking like you have your big brother's pants on.
If you're a little shorty.
I mean,
obviously,
do I really need to explain to people that if they actually take your fucking
measurements,
I mean,
if they take your measurements,
it's going to fit
the way it's supposed to fit,
you know,
and all of a sudden a women are going to be looking at you like,
Oh,
who's that guy?
Look at all fucking sharpened his suit.
Yeah.
As opposed to trying to hit the lottery.
It'd be like,
you know,
did the,
the,
the fucking person in El Salvador that sell this together,
you know,
was see the same size as me.
Guys love the wide selection of high quality fabrics and the option to
personalize all the details,
including your lapel lining and monogram.
That's Kinda cool that you can pick out your own lapel and aligning.
All right,
so later on that night,
you know,
when you're on your date and you take your jacket off and you fucking put it
around the back of the chair,
you get a little flash,
their monogram,
you've taken yourself seriously.
All of a sudden the woman thinks you fucking,
you run in something.
Um,
back when guys used to go buy a,
you know,
by the initial systems MHG well,
see,
here's how it works.
Visit a showroom or shop online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customizations,
submit your measurements,
wait for your custom suit to arrive.
And just a few weeks after,
fuck,
I need a suit for the rough and rowdy thing.
I should've ordered one through them
anyways,
this week my listeners can get any premium Indochino too,
for just 379 bucks@indochino.com when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code burr for any premium suit for just 379 bucks and
free shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off the rack
ever could.
Well,
I'm looking for a unique suits to wear at these rough and rowdy.
Thanks.
Alright,
so maybe I'll go through these guys,
you know,
provided everything.
I just think everything's going to go well at this,
provided the people at Barstool.
Want me to come back for the next one?
Cause I'm already,
I'm already ready to come back for the fucking next one and I haven't even been
to this one yet.
And it's on April 13th in Charlotte,
North Carolina.
Okay.
Um,
it's,
it's gotta be on pay per view.
I believe it's like 16 bucks.
It's the biggest no brainer ever.
Get your friends over,
sit down and just watch regular people talk shit and go in the ring.
It just fucking wail on each other.
It's,
it's the greatest fucking idea.
I don't know.
Every once in awhile I,
I know I keep saying this,
but you know,
I'm so site,
I'm going to have a ringside seats that we sit and rig site for the whole
fucking thing.
That'll be another added thing cause I don't know shit.
I don't know how to commentate.
I'm not Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan is borderline of fucking uh,
uh,
Moussad agent with his abilities and his understanding of combat.
Me On the other hand,
[inaudible] just going to sound like I was just some loud shithead.
Sit next to you on your couch.
Okay.
That's what I'm going to do.
Alright.
MVMT movement.
Uh,
here's my problem with sunglasses.
I didn't know I had a problem with sunglasses.
Why are you putting words in my mouth?
I got all these cheap pairs that look terrible.
No,
I don't.
I am Nice Fares.
Yeah.
But every time I buy 200 pay,
$200 pair,
I feel like I get ripped off.
That's not what I feel.
Here's my problem with sunglasses,
okay?
If you buy a fucking cheap pair,
they don't do anything.
You still squinting behind him.
Now your face is all mushed up wearing sunglasses.
You look like a fucking asshole and they're digging into the right above your
ear on your scalp.
But then if you buy a nice expensive pair,
then you got to sit there and I'm like,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
what if I,
what if I lose it?
What if I sit on in and inevitably that fucking happens.
Okay.
Movement.
That's what I feel about fucking sunglasses.
How dare you put words in my mouth
and I don't feel like I got ripped off.
If I paid $200 I feel like a fucking asshole when I lose them.
All right,
well our friends at at movement.
Yeah,
the watch guys,
they kind of felt the same way.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
They agreed with me so they,
they thought screw it.
I think they thought fuck it.
How about we make quality trendy glasses at a fair price.
These things aren't plastic.
They acetate.
You can get them polarized.
Is that a word?
As tape?
Ace tape.
I got to add that.
Where I'm going to fuck it.
I ain't gonna say it's a goal of mine today to throw that word in with my wife.
Yeah.
See what the fuck.
What the fuck does that mean?
Did you ever go look up a fucking word on Wikipedia?
What is that writing when you're trying to figure out how to spell it,
it looks like it's in Russian
is it is a salt form by a combination of
Seti Siddique acid with an alkaline,
earthy metallic base of fuck this out of.
I don't give,
I don't need to know what it means.
I just know how to say it.
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows what this fucking word means.
You just say it and people like,
wow,
that guy's guy's smart.
Look at,
look at his custom lining on a suit.
All right,
here we go.
Ready?
Everybody is this thing.
Okay.
If your support of this podcast,
you have to work this word into your day with somebody who you know very well,
who's going to know that you have no idea what this fucking word means and your
goal is to try and fucking play it off.
Like you've always had this in your arsenal,
like this was part of your fucking pitching rotation.
Here we go.
Come on,
say it.
Acetate,
you fucking
acetate.
There you go.
Kinda sounds like asshole,
doesn't it?
You fucking acetate.
Acetate,
Acetate to how creepy is this?
This is like,
it's the end of the world and that's like some warning in the future.
You know,
everybody gets the fuck Outta here.
You're
[inaudible]
I think we just lost Mike.
All right,
sorry about that.
Uh,
that was my,
my version of like alien.
All you need in the background that Acetate acetate.
Oh God.
What's going on here?
Acetate affects oil.
I like learning stuff when they,
when they have music that makes you not think this is shit.
[inaudible]
Hi Stanford.
Welcome to that has gotta be the worst fucking fade down ever.
Have anything.
Wasn't it?
[inaudible] hi.
Stanford's love them too to like crap.
Jesus Christ.
Acetate acetate in the future.
Someday when you're dumb enough to buy a fucking robot one day when it has a
glitch and you come walking in there and it hasn't even weirder robot expression
on his face and you're like,
uh hey,
what's up there?
Fucking r two d two and it's just looking at you going Acetate,
Acetate,
acetate.
Why,
why are you saying that man?
Slowly walking towards you.
Acetate.
Um,
anyways,
what the fuck was I talking about?
So sunglasses,
they have lots of styles to choose from.
Wait,
these things aren't plastic.
They acetate,
Acetate,
acetate.
You can get them polarized and they start at just $70.
There is seriously my goto shades.
I don't even have a fucking pair yet.
Send them to me.
I want these things.
Hey Bill,
would you get those sunglasses?
I'm just going to stare at them like the fucking terminator as that,
that authentic,
they are high quality premium Acetate,
Acetate,
acetate frames,
no cheap plastic care.
You got to see these.
They have lots of sales to choose from.
Classic Trendy Round Aviator mirrored polarized.
I love guns.
Fuck it.
That's polarized for him and for her.
You're sure to find the perfect pair.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to mvmt.com/burr
you know about movement for how they've Rebelo revolutionized the watch
industry.
They've already done that.
This is like a fighter that's moving up in weight class.
They already got that belt.
Now they're going to go for the next one.
Now's the time to check out their sunglasses.
Go to
movement.com/burr.
That's M v as in Victor,
m t as in tune to
lu.com/bird joined the movement.
Acetate acetate me undies,
everybody.
Oh,
here we go.
Boto doot,
doot me,
undies me undies.
Nice off shit against your taint.
Badu doot doot me,
undies me undies.
They don't fucking asset taint.
Why would you want that shit up against your skin?
Especially down there.
There is no wind.
Wash it off with you.
Ladies face.
Sorry.
Uh,
you've,
you've heard me talk about me undies and you know that I'm a big believer in
their product.
They're the perfect balance of comfort and fit every month,
have new and exciting prints and they arrive at your door in a fun bag.
Um,
yeah,
they sent me another sack on where one of them were like referee shorts.
I don't know how I felt about those.
It's like,
what am I gonna fucking be ratting people out now?
Thrown flags and stuff.
Uh,
me undies uses Lenzing micro modal.
What the fuck is Lenzing Lenzing Lenzing in their underwear.
It's sustainably sourced.
What does that mean?
They can grow more?
Are they planting Lenzing micro mode?
Madell trees naturally soft FIBA that starts with beechwood trees and ends with
the most amazing fabric you've ever experienced.
How the fuck he cut down a tree and make comfortable underwear is just,
just goes to show you the level of genius.
Although if you had to like,
you know,
put your under carriage up against the tree,
I think,
uh,
a beechwood tree would probably be in the nicer one.
You know,
it's got this smooth bar crime.
The results have been downright dreamy.
Me undies,
adventurous prints and designs are all limited edition and new patterns are
released every few weeks on a rolling basis.
100% satisfaction guarantee me undies guarantees you will love their undies or
your money back beyond.
These has a great offer for my listeners for any part time.
First Time purchasers.
When you purchase any me on days you get 20% off and free shipping beyond these
is so sure you'll love their underwear.
They offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair of,
you'll get a full refund.
This is a no brainer.
Get um,
get 20% off a pair of the most comfortable underwear you will ever put on.
Do you hear somebody screaming,
oh,
she's got the cartoons on.
Some weird lady came in the fucking room in the house.
I mean not to get 20% off your first pair of free shipping.
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
book hang on a second.
I gotta go to turn that down a little bit.
Little bit.
Great.
Hey Lady,
can you guys just turn that down just a little bit?
I'm trying to Acetate my podcast.
I'm good.
I'm just trying to Acetate this thing here.
You get it done,
right?
What's that?
You don't know what to ask.
Yeah,
I don't know if you could hear that.
I use acetate like two or three times and she just looks up.
She goes,
I don't know what that word means and I don't care too.
So that you go,
that's right.
You know that's a good one to use on your lady.
She'll think that you fucking moving on.
You know,
he see he getting smart acetate.
Get the fuck off me.
Okay.
See right there.
That's what I want to work on my temper.
I was just literally trying to bring the cord around my foot and I couldn't do
it because I'm not flexible enough and I just said get the fuck off me like it
was a person.
There's something wrong about that.
Um,
all right.
stamps.com stamps.com brings all the amazing services of
the US Postal Service right to your fingertips by and print official US postage
for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer stamps.
Dot coms makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale.
Automate automatically calculates exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you
decide the best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter.
Uh,
and there are no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com because,
um,
uh,
I don't know why you cause you fucking,
you buy advertising on this thing and I ended up using it.
It turned out to be easy,
but I do,
I,
you know,
I did it for the money man and then it turned out to be a great,
great thing and I don't have to go to the post office when I send out my fucking
posters.
All right.
Anyways,
uh,
and right now you too can enjoy stamps.
The stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage.
And a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone to top of the homepage and type in burger that
stamps.com enter bar.
Um,
okay.
All right.
What else did I want to talk about?
Oh,
another thing with that Garry Shandling think that that documentary really
affected me was,
you know,
one of the things that happens to a lot of comedians is,
uh,
whatever the fuck happened to us that made us become comedians.
Uh,
you just start chasing,
you know,
yeah.
Selling out clubs and get known and becoming famous and all that,
and thinking that that's going to fucking,
you know,
get rid of your demons and uh,
it doesn't.
And then you put off all the major party your life,
which is finding love and starting a family and all of that shit.
And,
um,
you know,
the other day I was talking to somebody and they were in their early thirties
and I brought up the Garry Shandling documentary and the person said,
who's that?
Right.
And then I also mentioned like a,
somehow I brought up Robin Williams and I mentioned that he had,
you know,
yeah.
Committed suicide a few years and she didn't even realize he was dead.
And she was just like,
Mrs Doubtfire.
And I was like,
in my head,
I'm just going,
these people are fucking legends.
And it's just like,
you know,
every generation has their people,
you know what I mean?
So it's like,
it was like so fucking profound where it's like you're chasing all of that
fucking shit.
And you know,
once she,
you know,
once you're past a certain age,
like no one's gonna give a shit anymore anyways.
So it's like you're trying to,
I don't know,
it's not like a tangible thing that you can depend on.
And I had this big fear when I was going through comedy that I was like,
uh,
I was like,
Oh man,
am I going to be the guy that doesn't get married and never has kids?
Because I've seen the other side of that as like,
I don't want to fucking,
I don't want to end up being that cliche.
And then just being that fucking,
that older fucking comic,
you know?
And then you've got your sport coat on to hide your middle and your talking to
you talking at this point you're hitting on women that don't know who your bands
are and don't know all,
all,
all your cultural references.
They don't even know who these fucking people are and the level of fucking
sadness that the,
how lonely that feeling would be.
I used to fucking wake up.
I didn't literally wake up and I would be laying in bed on the road thinking
about shit like that.
And when I was watching this documentary,
I remember,
you know,
thinking,
uh,
as I was watching Gary wrestling with his demons,
I literally said to me at one point,
I was like marrying you and having a kid.
He's the smartest fucking thing I ever did.
Thank God.
I know I did it late,
but thank God I fucking did that because if I didn't,
you know,
I'd be 70 years old in some fucking Goddamn hotel on the other side of this shit
when nobody gave a fuck.
And I would just be laying there drinking myself to death,
going Acetate,
acetate.
That literally makes me scared just saying that
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
I think what I'm going to do,
cause I don't think I'm a diary person,
but I think what I'm gonna do is I'm just going to kind of write down in the
beginning of the day,
just
I find it just one day of doing that.
It's really vivid and lives now rather than just being this fucking random
thought.
Like,
you know,
I need to work on this.
Maybe just have a fucking goal each day.
So my kid,
uh,
I can kind of kill off this fucking anger demon that exists in my family tree.
I would love to see my family tree.
It's got to look like it'd be this weird combination of like,
oh,
that's really nice,
but a little upsetting,
you know,
like a tree in a,
the beginning of winter,
um,
at a certain time of day,
you know,
that certain time of day would trees are beautiful,
but they start to look a little ominous.
That's probably what it would look like.
Um,
a tree that's trying.
All right.
Let's,
uh,
oh,
I didn't tell you guys about my fucking journey back from San Antonio.
So,
uh,
I had a 6:00 AM flight to Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
You know,
I normally I would have flown in the night before,
but I got the kid,
you know,
I can't,
can't miss those hours.
So I flew in,
no problem.
Everything was great.
The next day I had an 8:00 AM flight to San Antonio for whatever fucking reason.
I mean,
it's not that long a flight.
We're in the same time zone.
How come I couldn't get like the 10 o'clock flight,
right?
So we checked into the hotel,
we do the show,
everything's great.
And then the next morning I had a 6:00 AM flight and I got off stage at 12 and
couldn't get to sleep till like one 32 in the morning.
So,
uh,
it was just like,
all right,
I'll just sleep on the plane.
So we get up at like four 30 in the fucking morning,
quarter to five go down there.
And my big thing is when I only get like two hours sleep,
all I'm trying to do is get on the plane.
And once I get on the fucking plane,
it's like I'm just going to go to sleep,
you know,
I forgot my ims and one client always has to have their fucking shade up,
cause they're a morning person and fuck everybody else.
You know,
no consideration for somebody who just fucking stop working at,
you know,
12,
1230.
Right.
So we get there
and I'm laughing at dean cause we are like so fucking tired.
It's like you literally like you're hung over or like through.
All I gotta do is get on that plane and he's like,
I know I'm going to go right to sleep and then I'm going to land at seven 30 la
time,
right.
By the time I get to my fucking house,
it's gonna be eight 30.
My daughter just got up a half hour early.
I'm going to get that whole time with her before she does her first nap.
Fucking perfect.
Um,
and all of a sudden they're like,
uh,
the flights now gonna fucking leave at six 15,
you know,
cause they said they had to reset the airplane,
which I don't know what the fuck that means.
Is that some computer shit?
I have no idea.
And then six 15 became six 45 and I was like,
Oh God,
don't do this.
Please don't do this.
And then it became seven 45 and then it got fucking canceled.
And then because it was the final four,
all the fucking planes was sold out.
And the next one they could get us on was 7:00 PM.
And I was like trying to keep my cool,
which of course I didn't.
And they said,
sir,
it's okay.
We're going to send everybody on the seven o'clock flight.
We're going to send on an excursion today,
paid by Delta.
I'm like,
I don't want to go on an excursion.
I want to go to Los Angeles.
And she goes,
they're going to take you to see world.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
they gonna buy me a giant fucking lollipop.
I don't want to fucking,
I don't want to watch an incarcerated killer whale doing fucking jumping through
hula hoop.
Okay.
I don't want to see that.
What I would like,
can I go there and watch you set that fucking thing free again?
I would see that that would be worth it.
You know,
watch a jump over a little boy as it goes out out of the bay into a fucking the
ocean like free willy.
Um,
so anyways,
so we say Fuck Delta,
not fucked delta.
Literally fucked Delta,
but fuck this situation delta put us in,
cause I know all the airlines this,
it's just a,
it happens.
Okay.
The fucking planes not working right.
And I understand it,
but I'm also frustrated.
So I go down to southwest,
all of this shit is filled up.
Um,
so we're like,
what about Dallas?
Can you fly us to Dallas love field and we'll just fly back.
Can't do that.
Um,
and then we just said,
what about Austin?
And they go,
okay,
well Austin,
we have a 10:00 AM flight at this point.
It's like,
you know,
getting close tonight.
We have an 11 and we have a two 15.
So I'm like all right,
put us on the fucking two 15 and you know,
it's an hour and a half drive.
So Dean goes to get a fucking rental car.
And I said fuck this let's just Uber then we don't have to deal with picking up
the rental car,
the shuttle and all that.
So we did fucking ubered I passed out in the fucking car,
I got out of the car,
I left my fucking head phones in that,
this is my third time.
Second Time I've lost those Bose headphones.
Um,
I always keep the charge of though,
if anybody has a set of those silver fucking bows or the black ones and you need
that little charger cord,
uh,
send me your address and I'll mail it to you.
Um,
cause I'm going to have three of them is,
I just ordered another fucking pair.
So anyways,
uh,
we get out and we got there so fucking fast cause there was no traffic.
We actually got on the 1115 had to connect through fucking Phoenix.
It wasn't that bad and,
uh,
it all worked out.
And,
uh,
and because I had written down that Shit,
you know,
that I wanted to like maybe talk to somebody about my temper or something like
that.
Um,
I was actually completely aware that I was fucking snapping when I snapped like
that.
That's as far as I've ever been able to get to with my temper.
You know,
the old new,
I would just snap and not think about it.
Now I'm actually thinking about it as I do it and have no control over it.
So it's even more like tortures now because now like watching myself,
I,
yeah,
you go bill yelling at people that like built,
they're trying to save your life.
Do you think they're not flying because they want to go through this giant
fucking headache on some level,
they're probably losing money because one of their planes cannot fly.
Would you like to get up to a cruising altitude and then plunge back to the
fucking earth and never see your family again?
All boohoo you have to wait 12 hours to continue living.
He was selfish,
stupid cunt.
Um,
but I can't hear anything at that point.
I'm in the fucking acetate mode.
Um,
or I'm killing that joke.
Uh,
by the way,
I am so back into def Leppard now.
It's ridiculous.
I downloaded pyromania and uh,
what was it?
High and dry,
the one before that.
And uh,
I'm so into them.
I'm actually looking at lefthanded flying V's,
you know,
like maybe this is the guitar.
I'll know how to fucking,
I'll actually stick with,
um,
cause I was just watching their lineup,
but they,
what's that guy's name?
Pete Willis is the guy that they had on the,
on the high and dry.
And then they had,
um,
what's his face filled in for him?
Uh,
I always forget his fucking name and it's literally the same name as somebody
else.
Famous.
It's Phil Collen,
not Phil Collins.
He came in and filled in for,
um,
but like that,
that album,
uh,
pyromania when that came out,
that's just one of those albums that came out during this awesome time in your
life.
Um,
first time he had crushes on fucking chicks in your graded shit in that fucking
album came out.
You know,
and I did the,
and this is what I would do rather than thinking,
what can I say to this chicken,
my fucking class that I like this lady,
I would actually just,
I would just go home instead and I would listen to Pyromania fantasizing that I
was in the band playing the guitar and singing in front of the school.
And even in the fantasies,
she would just see me do it and I would still never talk to her.
I'm a fucking mess.
Um,
and that's what leads you then.
It's just like,
well,
I can't say it.
I can't play guitar.
I get so go up there and tell shit jokes,
I guess,
think they tell I became a comedian.
All right.
Rough and rowdy.
Charlotte April 13th.
Billy's going to wear a fucking silly suit and he's going to fucking make some
jokes.
You got to watch it.
Paper view.
Uh,
all right.
F One dear.
Silly Billy.
Greetings from Monaco,
all the sovereign state on the French Riviera originally from Portugal.
I'm a very big f one fan since I was four years old.
Well,
it seems like you saw the heyday of it,
the second golden age of it with Michael Schumacher.
Uh,
my grandfather says I wouldn't take my eyes off the cars even if a storm took
the roof off the house.
It's a beautiful and graceful sport despite how loud it can be.
I first saw you from Chappelle and then saw you on an interview on the Internet
from Montreal and my brother showed me because he's a huge fan of yours.
I now am too.
Oh,
that's great.
Thank you.
I think this is a very important time in f one the sport is going to continue to
move into the mainstream because the stars in the sports and the storylines of
competition are starting to match the popular culture of today.
Oh,
that's very,
uh,
what's the word
I'll,
I can think of is acetate.
That's a very astute analization.
Is that the word?
I don't know.
It can be very Shakespearian.
I appreciate you talking about the drivers with respect.
Even if you're not a fan of everything they do is incredible.
How talented these men are in.
Some women are able to navigate with it.
Some women are able to navigate with precision and it's hilarious.
Um,
little chauvinism there.
I would like very much to see you at more racism,
perhaps talking to drivers and Cruz.
Thank you.
And bless your family.
Yo,
you and me both.
Oh look who's here.
A lovely Nia and my lovely daughter.
You know what she has the cutest onto this year is on these gray sweatpants and
pants with this matching Hoodie,
that short sleeve.
It looks like you've got a little Belicheck.
Hi,
how are you?
How was your breakfast?
You rant and rave and screaming,
yelling your podcast for damn near 15 years.
And you know,
I never say anything.
And then I'm having breakfast with our lovely daughter and we're laughing and
we're joking and we're singing songs.
And you have the nerve to come in and tell us to keep it down a cup of cheese.
I know.
No,
I'm just,
uh,
yeah,
but this is also putting a roof over our head.
What's up buddy?
How you doing?
We can have fun today.
Huh?
The itsy bitsy spider went up.
The Wad is about
dried up all the raid and itsy bitsy spider went up the style and again,
Yay.
Aww,
look at that smile.
All right.
You want to read some of these with me now?
Okay,
what do we got here?
Um,
oh yeah,
I absolutely would love to talk to the drug.
This guy is saying he's from Portugal,
he now lives in Monaco.
How much is this guy crushing it and this is listen to what he says about female
drivers near let's do this.
He says it's incredible how talented these men are and some women are able to
navigate with precision.
Oh thanks.
Thanks for that.
Some women are what?
What?
Where is it going with this?
He was just saying that he would love to see me talking to more drivers and
being in more,
more racist.
Oh,
well I know you would like that.
I would love that.
And I think if I could navigate with precision down to the pit area and if you
don't trip and fall because you're a woman,
right?
Yeah.
I'm a chauvinist pig and I attract these people.
They need a pot chauvinist needs podcast too.
All right,
let's,
let's talk about 45.
She like records,
right?
Huh?
Hey Sweetie,
you want to talk about 40 fives,
Huh?
Yeah.
You're going to tell us his story.
What's so crazy right now is she totally has obviously has all these thoughts
and she knows what she's saying,
but she doesn't understand that we don't talk her jibberish so she'll just be
sitting there making all these hand movements like she's making these profound
points that she's going,
I shake shack he retired and she's still making was he's still into that noise
that she can't check crap that she was doing.
Okay.
Can you say baby?
He say baby.
Huh?
Nah,
go.
She said it.
I say you liked that frog and I break by date due to Michigan.
All right.
45,
eight Billy burger hole.
A long time fan of the podcast.
Well,
thank you.
I travel a lot in your Massachusetts vibes.
Always remind me of home,
uh,
recently.
Don't touch that.
Um,
recently.
it's so funny.
They always go for like the thing that's going to hurt them the most is all this
stuff here,
shoes,
chairs and all that goes right for the hot tea.
Uh,
recently my fiance and I surrendered our weekend nights to playing card games
alongside tasty beers at home.
I should just playing 45.
That sounds like fun.
We would just say in how we hate those.
Like you go to those parties with other adults and they have game night,
so he's fucking cards against humanity and all of that stuff.
I don't want to do that.
Um,
but we've got to get to bring back cards,
right?
That's a game night.
If you play cards,
you have a,
it's a cool,
it's only playing mad libs.
I like cards against humanity though.
I feel like if you get kind of high or a little bit drunk,
Adolf Hitler's date
to pits,
the jokes in cards against humanity are as bad as when you fly southwest.
I hate to make fun of them cause I love that airline.
But listening to those people do comedy.
I just can't,
I get angry at the people encouraging them through.
This guy was sitting,
they were going down the uh,
you know,
we're going down the runway,
like we'll go on the tarmac or whatever and he's doing the Darth Vader voice or
everybody put on your feet and people like,
Ooh,
no,
it just annoys me that that person doesn't get heckled.
Cause it's just like if I,
if I did a joke like that,
people will be throwing their chair at me and this guy's getting laughs because
I feel like maybe people feel obligated because it's the,
the flight crew and you want to be on their good side.
It's exactly what it is,
that it's the awkward silence and people are just in,
in,
in the silence of the joke bombing people then laugh because they feel
uncomfortable because this is overall nervousness that what we're about to do
could kill us.
So then the level of comedy that they have to do,
you know what I mean?
When you're scared,
you'll laugh at anything.
You just walk in like,
uh,
the rain's really coming down,
isn't it?
It's like you didn't say anything funny there.
Wow.
That was close.
Nervous laughter.
There we go.
Uh,
I suggest playing 45,
which I know.
Nia.
You kidding me?
No,
that'd be cool.
We got it.
We got,
we got to get a cool stereo man.
Yeah.
You know what?
We should have our own kind of like night,
you know,
and music and you and me.
Why don't we do that?
Yeah.
Sing some songs.
Oh,
hug and kiss a little bit with a little ones down.
Why don't we do this instead of sitting there going like,
what?
Over the head a little bit.
Yeah.
I like it.
Sort of sit in their cars again.
Here.
We as old,
I think southwest writes those punch lines on those stupid cards.
I just don't like that.
You don't write the punchline and then you get credit for it.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
I'm too,
I'm too into the John too far deep into the joke.
Gay Man.
Yeah,
right.
I don't know.
Anyways,
we could hardly find any rule.
Okay.
I suggest playing 45 which I can,
which I had always played growing up on the north shore,
uh,
in trying to find the rules online.
I was surprised to learn that it's pretty endemic to Massachusetts.
What rules?
What are we talking about?
Oh,
we thought he met at 45 as an records fives.
It's obviously some kind of game that we don't know about.
We thought you were talking about,
oh,
they don't know about 45 like you don't know what acetate means?
I guess so.
Yeah.
We can hardly front.
Can you do me a favor?
Can you say acetate three times in a row with a pause and just no life in your
voice between each one?
Just pause.
Just say acetate three times in a row.
Okay.
Acetate.
Slower
acetate.
Longer.
Pause.
That was pretty good.
Okay.
We'll definitely call you back for the audition.
So what was his thing?
We can hardly find the rules anywhere.
In any case,
just curious whether you ever played this game growing up or had any other
traditions you found to be a Massachusetts thing once you left.
Thanks and hope you can come to Vermont or Montreal sometime soon.
Okay.
Yes and yes.
Oh,
I'm so old.
I thought stand by records.
That's what I thought it was for.
Somebody gave me some records and Tulsa and then they don't,
one of them was a 45.
Um,
so many.
I have to get the adapter.
Watch it.
No,
you just,
when you're just,
you just want to spill that don't ya?
Alright.
40 45 game.
Yeah.
Speaking of game,
hold on a sec.
Yeah.
45 [inaudible] 45 it's a card game.
Yeah,
that's what I figured.
All right.
Why is my Internet's so slow?
The Ace of heart is always the best third box.
I was played with a regular deck of cards.
This isn't like old may do you guys remember?
Old Maid,
you know,
and then the classic that I never played granny fucking water.
There's another case,
there's another card game.
Nia did.
Everybody in the Midwest knows about,
uh,
euchre and that game would Joe Barton,
Nick and j law had talked about euchre.
They were like freaking out.
They were going like entire families had stopped talking to each other on
because of that game.
That game is evil.
That's like a Pittsburgh,
Cleveland,
Detroit,
that type of area.
I think people play Euchre uh,
the ace of hearts is always the third best.
Trump.
Yeah.
We,
this is good.
This is good.
Clean Fun here.
The deal.
Robbing the Trump object of the game.
The goal is to accumulate the most chips by winning tricks.
How to keep score irregularities.
You're going to do this.
This is,
this is a game night bill.
So I don't know why you're talking about you're so against the game night.
This is what cause I don't like,
you know what?
I don't like the modern games.
I'll play cards.
My grandmother was a,
was zone.
Amazing.
And my aunt against humanity.
You have a plate flinch.
No.
Flinches another one.
Uh,
I,
we get what you're going to get all these card games.
Have you ever played spades as a black people play?
Uh,
oh,
look at me.
Do you ever play hearts?
That's what white people play.
No.
All right.
Oh,
we gotta we gotta get some cards,
man.
We gotta get some cars.
We explore each other's like heritage through card games.
Yeah.
You teach me spades.
I gotta remember how to play harder part.
You don't know how to play spades.
I've maybe played it.
I knew black people play dominoes.
Well,
no,
we're not talking about dominoes.
So talking about a card game,
I know we're not talking about Domino's.
Why could you just give me that?
That I actually knew something that that was like the Chappelle show sketch.
I know black people with Domino's is,
come on.
I just said,
okay.
Jesus.
Okay.
Sorry.
She's so protective.
She's so protective of her culture.
You know that Nia,
you market this little,
oh,
you kissing the baby.
Oh Hey.
Yeah.
Why are you so protective?
Huh?
Do you want to start an argument with,
you know,
why are you so protective of your culture?
Why don't you let me,
you've never taught me how to taught me how to do let you in.
I was going to say,
you never taught me how to do the,
uh,
do you know Nia could do the whole Janet Jackson Rhythm Nation Dance?
No.
Miss you much Osu man.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
She'll just bust that out out of fuck.
Sorry.
Out of nowhere.
And she could really do it.
You know what I mean?
It's still like me.
I could do like the peewee Herman did ed debt a debt that I think I'm all
impressed.
Oh,
they have all impressive,
right?
China's surveillance.
Oh,
Nia.
You know,
people are gonna ask you to fucking Instagram that.
I know it's not going to happen.
No.
Okay,
I'm back.
Sorry.
The,
uh,
the batteries just died in this thing.
Um,
all right.
We are,
I think I'm well over an hour here at this point.
I have to be,
I don't really know where I'm at at this point.
All right.
Jane is surveillance man.
If,
if,
uh,
you want me to just do the rest of this because it seems like she's getting
ready to,
uh,
run around here.
So I just don't know if that's going to be annoying to people to hear going on.
[inaudible] I'm sitting here talking about all this stuff durable to them as it
is.
Yeah.
That's the one thing you got to remember.
Your kid is adorable to you
everywhere.
Everybody thinks the kids are adorable.
Then after awhile it's just like,
okay.
Okay.
Um,
China's surveillance,
dear bill,
Bunker Hill.
I love it.
I'm a software engineer.
Makes sure she doesn't shut her hands in the door there.
Um,
oh down like a ton of bricks.
It is amazing that they always fall in there,
but
yeah.
All right buddy.
Okay.
Alright,
Cutie Pie.
I'll see you in a few minutes.
Bye Bye.
Kiss.
Oh,
all right,
I'll see you.
Lovely ladies out there.
All right.
I'm a software engineer and system integration specialists at a prominent firm
in a major city.
I won't state my political affiliation because I know you hate that move as much
as I do.
Good.
Let's get into it.
I'm terrified that my children will have little to no privacy in their adult
lives being intact.
I'm becoming aware of the capabilities and advances in surveillance systems and
as an ordinary human being with the Internet,
I've maintained and understanding that our government under both parties have
been constantly expanding their surveillance reach and continue to lie to us
about what information is being stored.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
And all the major fucking news organizations don't say anything about it.
They don't do anything to protect us.
They just sit there fucking making money.
Uh,
China isn't very different.
it's definitely more aggressive and more intrusive.
The biggest is what Snowden was trying to warn us about.
We all left that guy twist and on the vine and everybody was afraid because they
wrapped what this guy was doing into trying to beat Isis.
So then it's like,
well,
I can't say anything because then I don't support the troops and then I'm going
to get the Dixie chicks fucking treatment.
Um,
that's,
that's all.
That's all they're fucking doing right now.
It's just destroying people individually.
Um,
snowed is a fucking hero as far as I'm concerned.
God Damn fucking loony Texas.
It's like,
how much more do they need to know about?
You just sit down at the airport,
you go through fucking security.
Then it's like you don't understand in that.
Now go now,
go through Tsa.
You got to answer all this shit and get fucking fingerprinted and now,
now that line's clogged up,
so now the next one,
people are fucking stick in that goddamn retinas in there.
It's unbelievable.
All right.
Drop your pants and spread your butt.
Cheeks is going to be the next one.
Don't get through the line fucking quicker and people would do it because it'll
be more convenient.
All right.
The biggest difference is that they have the decency to not try and hide it or
maybe you think it's better to be lied to?
I Dunno.
Well,
I think it's because China could just fucking,
you know,
I don't,
as far as I know in mainland China at the level of rights that you have versus
what you have over here.
I think over here you have to lie because they don't have the right to do what
they're doing.
Probably,
I dunno,
this article lays out the way in which our government surveillance is going to
be able to access everything in a Chinese citizens life,
both at work and at home,
um,
in which government on our government,
one of the most important in advancements being made is not just the collection
of data,
but the sorting
or of data and the ability to sift through billions of communications for
specific content.
This is why the FBI and CIA have had information on terrorist activity,
but it had no way to access it if through all the bullshit.
Yeah.
So the thing is,
so what people would say was,
well,
as least as little,
as long as I'm not out there trash in a,
you know,
saying I'm a Moose slum,
I won't have a problem,
uh,
back to my kids,
Mo I,
because this is the thing.
They're going to use that to then access all this other shit as they always do,
as they always do.
Um,
back to my kids.
Most government technology eventually makes it,
makes its ways to the public.
When my children are in their adult life,
all of their previous years will be stored somewhere to create a case against
them based on the person that they were and not who they've become.
Jesus Christ.
That last statement,
there might be most intelligent thing anybody's ever sent in.
Um,
I will send you guys,
um,
this,
this link to this story and read it and it just be informed and know that you're
going to be all right.
All right.
Cause I don't want to send all this doom stay shit that's gonna make you go into
a depression.
But you also do need to know.
It would be nice if people knew what was going on and uh,
I think like,
uh,
this is a time where people,
I just feel like everybody wants to start speaking up like what are we doing?
And not in an anti USA fucking way,
but you know,
at some point somebody has to kind of step up here.
You know,
I think we kind of need to look at the finances of how much is fucking
non-ending war is costing us.
And,
uh,
at some point we're going to have to pay all of that back.
$700 billion a fucking year.
I mean,
I would really be,
would really be a sad thing if 3,500 fucking jerk offs that train on a jungle
gym where to bankrupt this great nation.
They mean some point we do have to,
there has to be a way to discuss that without somebody yelling at you saying you
don't support the troops just to,
you know,
cause maybe they have it worked out.
Maybe there was a solution.
It would be nice as a citizen
who's paying ungodly taxes,
who would like to see them go to some shit over here,
like pup making public schools good again.
You know,
maybe get some people off the streets that need some help.
all these shutter island people fucking walking around.
They used to have facilities that they could go to.
You combine that with the fact that they can now go in and buy a bazooka and not
have to wait longer than three fucking minutes.
And all of a sudden you starting to have some problems.
You fucking call me mother fucker.
Don't bring that up.
Why did I blame the south for that?
You know,
that's not true.
I should sound like I got to get a good,
good,
good corporation.
Impression,
you're clearly against the United States of America.
Uh,
wife believes in ghosts.
Oh Jesus.
Dare Billy Burger basket.
Um,
I love my wife dearly in a most topics we are in agreement,
but recently something has come between us.
She believes in ghosts and I do not,
uh,
dude fucking let it go.
Who gives a shit?
Okay.
As long as she's not trying to talk to them,
if it's in acting like Whoopi Goldberg and saying that they're entering her
body,
but even then,
if she does that,
to just dedicate one of your rooms to that and just have her fucking make money
off of other dopes that believe what she's doing is real
anyways.
I'm not so bothered by her belief shirts a bit.
Kooky,
but she's free to do it and so it's not hurting anyone.
All right.
There you go.
The problem is,
is that she's offended that I don't believe in ghosts as well.
Oh Gee,
look at that.
I gave you a lecture and you are already fucking,
you were already where I was telling you to go.
It's like,
okay,
you believe in ghosts.
Good for you.
But I don't fine.
Oh,
cross.
Is there anything worse than cold tea?
Sorry,
I just started coughing.
I had to take a little swig there.
Um,
yeah,
I stopped believing in ghosts around the same time.
I stopped believing in Santa Claus and the Easter Bunny back when I was a kid.
So when a full grown adult tells me they see spirits,
I can't help but wonder if there's something wrong with them mentally.
She is afraid to go to the restroom at a certain restaurant in our town because
this a story about it being haunted.
She says the last time she went in there,
she felt in Erie chill,
but it's a draftee bathroom in a 90 year old bill building for Christ's sake.
She also has this old photographs she took through a window and an abandoned
mental hospital that she claimed shows a ghost face.
When I look at it,
I only saw blurry bullshit.
I tried to be nice about it,
but I think she felt like I was calling her stupid or crazy when I didn't see
it,
when I didn't see it too.
I didn't want to lie about it.
Besides,
she would know if I was lying.
Anyways.
I don't know how to approach this topic without upsetting her.
Do you have any advice for me?
Yours truly.
Um,
this guy left his fucking name and I don't know if this is a reference to
somebody,
a movie.
Let me see.
Yes,
this has gotta be somebody's,
uh,
this thing has to be a movie joke.
Oh,
doctor Peter Venkman.
okay.
This is Bill Murray's character and Ghostbusters.
Okay.
Hilarious.
All right.
Um,
I don't know how to approach this topic without upsetting her.
Do you have any advice for me?
Yours truly Dr Peter Venkman.
Uh,
yet don't bring up the topic.
Okay.
Don't bring up the topic and uh,
you know,
so I would just,
I would just be like,
look,
I get it.
You believe in ghosts and I don't,
uh,
don't say it like that.
Just be like,
I respect the fact that you believe in ghosts
and um,
I don't,
and if the tables were turned and there was something that I believed in and you
didn't,
I would respect the fact that you didn't.
And uh,
rather than,
you know,
getting upset with you.
Okay,
you see ghosts,
evidently you are born with the power that I was not giving.
So you should feel thankful for that,
that you're able to see these things.
I am a mere mortal.
Oh,
don't say that.
Cause then that's passive aggressive.
I'm the worst.
Something along those lines.
And just say,
listen,
I love everything about you and we get along great.
But I,
I just feel like there's this tension about this that,
that you're trying to force me to feel something that I don't feel and I don't
think that that's what you do to somebody you love.
And I wouldn't do that to you.
Okay.
So come on over here and if there's not it goes between us.
Could you give me a hug
some along those lines?
All right,
last one here.
My sister's friend.
Oh boy.
Hey Buddy.
Hi Bill.
You can't,
I'm an 18 year olds from England and I need some advice.
All right.
You pasty,
crooked teeth dose around two months ago.
One of my sister's childhood friends came to visit her for a weekend.
They'd been friends since they were three and she moved five hours away when she
was 12 so they barely see each other anymore.
They were playing to go out on Saturday with a group of friends say,
and I was planning on staying home alone when my sister went to pick up a few of
her friends to meet at our house.
Me and her friends flirted a bit,
but nothing major.
We exchange snapchats,
et cetera.
I love how that's flirting now.
Long time.
Long story short,
my sister's friend pretended to be ill and came home early so we could hook up.
Dude,
you are fucking crushing it.
You assist is bringing them home to,
you know,
you have to go out.
Good for you.
The only thing was my sister was genuinely ill and also came home early around
30 minutes after her friend and she caught us in bed together.
Well,
what the fuck is she doing walking into your bedroom?
My sister got insanely angry and stormed out by,
you should have said,
hey,
don't hate the player.
Hate the game.
And it just lit a cigarette.
Oh my God.
I think this is fucking funny.
This is fucking hilarious there.
Do you realize how hard you're crushing it?
You're fucking at home.
You're not even trying to get late.
She just says her friends come over for the bullshit.
Okay ladies,
you ready to go out and in that moment,
whatever the fuck you did made one of them pretend to be sick and come back and
hook up with you.
Dude,
you're a fucking hero.
Okay.
There's no reason to get,
oh,
I don't care how mad you sister gets.
Just,
I would just just keep smiling and just be like,
Hey,
am I can't help it,
man.
I,
you know,
the ladies loved me,
sweetheart,
sweetheart.
I wasn't trying to hook up.
I was at home.
I was innocent.
I can't help it.
If women are attracted to me,
I would just go totally fucking arrogant.
And the matter she get,
I would just keep laughing and I would never take it seriously.
Uh,
my sister has suffered with depression and anxiety.
I forget what,
I just,
I didn't see that part.
My sister's suffered with depression and I'm so excited for you that I didn't
even read this next part.
She suffered with depression and anxiety for years.
So whenever something like this happens,
my family almost always sides with her.
Oh,
that's easy.
Then you just divide and conquer with the,
with your dad.
Just be like,
Dad,
I can't help but I,
I inherited your charisma.
What do,
what do you want from me?
She,
I,
I didn't go out with,
she came home to me,
it fell,
it fell right in my lap.
What was I supposed to do?
Dad?
You know?
And he'll,
I don't,
there's no fucking way I get mad at my kid in the morning.
I mean,
he's mad because you're making her upset,
but he's not mad at what you did.
I'm guaranteed your dad's telling his friends at work,
his fucking son of a bitch and you have to leave the fucking house.
They come in,
they come in to him.
Uh,
in the morning she threatened to never talk to me again for what I did,
but I said something along the lines of,
I feel a connection with her
or some bullshit like that to calm my sister down.
The thing was I didn't,
but her friend did.
Oh No.
We started dating and after around two weeks I re I realized that I fucking
hated this girl.
She is genuinely as shit.
Yeah.
This is all good.
This is all good stuff because you're learning lessons which you're supposed to
in life,
especially at 18.
Okay.
This whole thing started with the lie.
And that you did to protect your sister's feelings.
So you just got to come clean.
You've got to dump the dummy and just tell her like,
listen,
I love you so much that I actually started dating somebody that is fucking
stupid.
All right,
I'm sorry you have that.
Then she'll get mad that you'll be like calling her friends stupid.
Are you saying my friends is stupid?
No,
I'm saying that friend that is a friend of you is stupid.
The other ones seem really smart and you know,
tell all of them.
I wouldn't mind if they fake six and came home and hooked up with
all right.
I realized that I fucking hated this girl.
She's generally stupid as shit.
My original plan was to pretend I was into her for a few months and then when I
go to university,
mmm.
In a few months I'd break up with her because of the long distance.
Dude,
don't do that because you might break her heart.
All right.
But that's some dumb shit you do when you're 18.
Uh,
that way I'd saved my relationship with my sister and mother and get rid of this
stupid bitch.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Don't talk about women.
You don't need to talk about him like that.
Okay.
Feel lucky that you know,
you got a better brain than cheated.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't play with people's feelings like that.
All right?
Cause I'm telling you right now that if you're any sort of an actual human being
,
uh,
breaking somebody's heart,
the guilt of that never fucking goes away.
Um,
however,
I recently received news that my first choice university turned me down and my
second choice was the only one that accepted me.
The problem is she lives 15 minutes away from my second choice university and
now I don't know what to do.
You've got to come clean.
I can't go through university hitched to a girl I fucking hate,
but I can't afford to risk my relationship with my family for obvious reasons.
Also,
another girl who I think I generally may have a connection with recently broke
up with her boyfriend of two years and I'm pretty sure that if I could,
if I could,
we would be dating right now.
Uh,
it also doesn't help that this girl is a nine out of 10 looking model and I'm
probably a six and a half out of 10 at best.
Thanks for you.
Help you freckled Twat all right.
Through this is what you got to learn.
You're going to learn,
uh,
honesty here.
All right?
I'm fucking break up with that woman today.
And you have to come clean,
okay.
With everybody in your house and you have to say,
you know,
you have to put your foot down that your parents cannot be choosing.
I maybe I would have this conversation with your parents.
They can't be choosing your sister over you straight across the board because of
your sister's depression and anxiety issues.
Okay.
I don't know how severe they are.
All right.
If there are chemical,
then yeah,
that's a major problem.
But you know,
if she just needs to fucking,
yeah.
You know,
get out of a funk then.
I Dunno.
I don't know where she is on the whole depression spectrum if that's the proper
thing.
But like,
you shouldn't have to be suffering like this,
dude,
you got to live your own fucking life.
All right?
Just live your life.
Live your life.
When you live your life,
sometimes people are going to get hard.
All right?
Fuck that.
Break up with this woman and go ask the other woman out.
That's it.
That's what the fuck you do.
And if anybody in your family has a problem with it,
let them vent to you and all that stuff and just say,
I'm sorry that I am doing what my heart is telling me to do.
All right.
I am not trying to hurt anybody in this family.
Had I known that hooking up with that girl was gonna,
uh,
cause this level of,
of drama,
I wouldn't have done it.
I regret that I did it.
I actually felt so bad that I actually fucking dated her for two weeks the whole
time.
And it was like talking to a fucking chair.
Say all this stuff nicely.
Okay.
All right.
There's a woman that I like,
then I want to pursue and I'm going to do that.
And if that's wrong,
that God damn it,
I don't want to be right and walk out.
Yeah.
Okay.
And don't let them hold your sister's fucking problems over your goddamn head
because that's,
look what it's already doing.
It's causing you to fucking date people you don't want to date.
So then she's going to be depressed and you're going to be living this life of
fucking misery because you didn't do what you wanted.
Okay?
Now,
having said that,
don't call women bitches,
all right?
Don't do that.
I'm not saying don't call them out on this shit and stand your ground,
but they don't.
Don't have a do the name calling thing,
all right?
Because it's,
it doesn't die.
Get you.
Not only does it and it makes the other person not hear what your point is,
then they can bring that up for the rest of your fucking relationship and God
knows they're going to do it.
All right?
That's the fucking podcast.
Oh,
fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Bye Bye.